you're surrounded by it so
all these stereotypes that
that uh you know it goes along with
racism
you're surrounded by
by all of them
in prison like you're surrounded by
uh the the uh
you know
the um epitome of cracker or [ __ ] or
[ __ ] or whatever
you are
that's the people you're with
where the name comes from you know the
reason why people
say that about that race is
the reason why are those people that
you're with
so i mean you're gonna end up racist not
to mention these um
the system
is uh separated anyway
yeah by race so you became a skinhead
when you were in prison no
no no i uh
when i was younger my older brother
was um
was sort of like a bigger
guy in a skinhead gang
a pretty big
um
[Music]
pretty large gang like
where um
[Music]
like they ran they ran in the whole area
and it was
actually quite large which is kind of
rare for white to have gangs like that
where is this
this is in duarte like a dwary area like
the san gabriel valley yeah
yeah
um
and i just took a like you know a
younger brother
you know monkey seemed like you do and
so i you know i had little red
suspenders and shaved head and all that
stuff and
i had no idea what i was doing of course
you know
didn't care i just
i was just kidding
but uh
yeah i got out of hand pretty quickly
uh because i got a nickname called
knuckles they call me knuckles
because i used to fight a lot so it
didn't go along really well with the
whole
gang
mentality
just sort of added fuel to the fire
and i was constantly getting kicked out
of school having to be brought home
um because i just would snap
and just uh
i just beat people up if anybody got
anybody subsequently afterward was in my
way
they got hit two of teachers
males females didn't matter i was just
like a
like a maniac
in fact the principal offered me one
time to if i didn't hit somebody for 30
days that he would um
he would buy me mcdonald's for lunch
and uh take me to a dodger game
if i just went 30 days without hitting
somebody
and uh
i couldn't even do that
i remember that
he had a school from throwing a black
kid into a holly bush because he stepped
in like he was doing something something
some real minuscule or whatever but
i beat him up real good and threw him in
a holly bush where he was he couldn't
move because he kept getting stabbed he
was like really one of those rough holly
bushes so i got a lot of trouble for
that
eventually got sent to my dad
um in georgia
uh
and it wasn't really much better being
that he wasn't
always there you know he's a
he's a tier one special operations guy
like uh
with like a
with like a top secret clearance and
he's always he's
there's a demand for that man uh
and even after he retired he's a
civilian contractor and he does
he does like um
extra extra extra extra training courses
on
for tier one operatives like deltas and
seals and stuff like that
if later on in their career they want to
take these other classes these courses
and pass them in it just as their jacket
you know
so he does one on close quarters knife
fighting you know
halo jumping like high altitude
jumping
so he was never home he was always at
fort bragg or fort benning or somewhere
so we were just basically now me and my
two brothers
the same ones they also got kicked out
and sent to uh not yeah i kicked out for
say but my mom couldn't handle it
um
because things were just spiraling out
of control with us
so we were left alone in georgia with a
bunch of guns
and like no snow um
supervision no parental guidance
actually no i would i can't i can't i
wouldn't say that
my father
he
he didn't raise a fool you know he he
there's
when he was around that was the only
thing is he wasn't there when he was
around he was fantastic
fantastic man
um
like lucky lucky to have him for father
compared to comparatively speaking to
other people but the fact is that he
wasn't there and we were left to our own
devices and
and um
yeah like i said we had all kinds of
guns and
drugs and
it was just it was just
madness my brother shot me one time i
remember
i got shot by my brother
um
i'm not sure if there's too much malice
behind it but
nevertheless it happened
and um but the small town that we that
we lived in they had like this one
little um urgent care sort of thing
i wouldn't even call it a hospital just
sort of a building by the high school
you know
that day apparently
they weren't taking any new patients for
some reason
um i don't know i think the lady was
just being a [ __ ] um
because my dad said my dad's a real um
real battering ram of a person you know
like uh
he's uh
37 years of navy seal in vietnam is he's
just say no more yeah um
um
so we went in there and uh they said
we're not taking any new patients
and i was like i was like 11 or probably
11 or 12 or something
had blood running down my arm you know
just got shot by my brother
and it's like not taking any patience so
my dad pissed off you know we got back
in the car
drove home and
and uh
he said i'm gonna have to do it you know
myself or whatever
um
that's not too much of a strange thing
for him to dig a bullet out of somebody
i'm sure he did it many times
but um
he uh
i remember he gave me a white
wash rag
a wet wet wash rag and um
told me to bite down on it and he
actually gave me
i remember he let me cuss that day
from the because when he did it like uh
he let me say he let me cuss that day
and he gave me a swig of vodka which is
horrible i remember it tasted so bad
so those two things
i remember and then he cut an accident
and just popped it out because it went
through some of the tree it didn't it
didn't go quite through my arm all the
way
uh it bubbled up like a big gray pimple
you know like a really really big like
tall pimple
and
you can see the metal color through my
skin like it was almost out i mean
almost just almost out
but because it went through the i was
standing in front of a tree like this
and my brother was shot the tree
but it passed through
just the edge of the tree like this so
um enough to slow it down but not to
stop it so slow it down enough to where
it wouldn't make it through my tricep
right here
and so he just cut an x over it
and popped it out like that
so went all the way through your arm
came out the other side um no it didn't
come quite out that's what i'm saying it
pushed itself all the way to the yeah
but your dad helped it come out yeah
yeah he just he cut it out yeah
yeah okay
that's just that's just a good example
of how um
things got a little out of hand back
then
you made it through high school
yeah you know i made through high school
i have a um
i have uh what the doctor or the psych
whatever told me i had a identic memory
whatever that is
really good memory so i tested really
well
um
which was
it maybe didn't make me popular with it
with the uh with the academic people
it seemed to drive them a little nuts my
test scores were always better i had a
perfect
gpa
my grades were perfect
i was college prep courses everything
like that
[Music]
uh but it didn't didn't it wasn't what
didn't uh
how do you say uh
it didn't um correlate cory it didn't
match my lifestyle you know
um
because i was uh you didn't have to try
no i'd have to try and i'd uh but
i i was a there's a i was the drug
dealer at high school um
always getting suspended for you know i
was i was a bad kid a straight a drug
dealer yeah exactly it didn't make much
sense
um
honors night i remember one night at
honors um i got the most
awards for honors that
but and i was the only one that didn't
show up for it
they called my name like a dozen times
and it wasn't even there
i don't know
so it's kind of weird but
school was really boring
i remember that
and i just i just i've been doing drugs
ever since i can remember
when you start i'm about seven years old
i guess seven yeah i took a i took a
bong rip at um at a park
with some wheat
and drank a forty
forty ounce beer liquor why do you think
that happened so soon in your life um i
believe that um
what was surrounded by it i never hung
out with children my own age
i was um
always
when i was seven
the people i was hanging out with were
were junior high skateboarder
head
pot smokers beer drinkers
um
so i
i went straight from like
and even before that i could clean a
rifle when i was
three years old
um
you know before i was even hanging out
with other people i was hanging out with
my older brothers and
stuff like that you know
[Music]
so i've just been i guess i won't say
bad but i've just been i guess i've been
bad you know my whole life i guess
or what the culture would deem
bad
yeah do you think that's just
you were genetically predisposed to that
or
um was it something you were exposed to
not genetically i think it was just a
lack of
lack of parental presence i guess
you know
and
stuff like that like
my father didn't condone any sort of bad
behavior or anything he he
if he anything about me and marijuana
you know i was in big trouble
anything anything i did wrong i wasn't i
was in big trouble until i turned 18
years old and he smoked a joint with me
to my surprise
but i mean up until that day he would
not have any part of it like
he was he was
yeah he didn't condone any of that
behavior at all
we got away with it because he wasn't
there like
what's your relationship like now with
your dad oh it's good
yeah he's my best friend that's great
yeah
he knows what you're going through now
um
not necessarily it's sort of like a
i'm sure he does he's a smart man you
know but i don't my dad's my dad's like
a millionaire like a really rich wealthy
man
and um i don't ask him for money ever so
he assumes that i'm doing okay you know
like uh
and i make a point to do that my older
brothers do it all the time
and i make a point to
the last thing i'm ever going to do if i
need money i'm going to do
anything and everything i can before i
ask him for money
because everybody else does it
and
i'm just not going to be there
you're a drug addict with morals
i guess so or i don't know drug addicts
with um
pride
pigheaded pride integrity yeah i guess
maybe i don't know
your what's your drug
um i use opiates
crystal meth
i smoke marijuana i drink
but uh primarily i have to do opiates
every day is that fentanyl or fentanyl
currently yeah fentanyl
just due to its potency nothing else
will suffice right
so i have to do that and
you know miscellaneous ways of making
money
uh that's what's the darkest way you've
made money i guess prostitution um
debt collecting
um
i appreciate your honesty yeah because i
think that's the answer every male would
give
if they were honest yeah i mean
i just you ask you know i i'm really i'm
really straight forward as well like um
hey
she's having a lot of trouble with women
if they ask me a question and it looked
bad in the dress i said yeah you do you
know i i have no um no filter i'm not
euphemistic about anything at all and i
don't know it's not on purpose it's just
you'll be brutally honest that's the
easiest way i'm just about the easiest
way
you know
lying and doing this and that that's
more work for me
you know i have something
it's just more work
my am i into that
efficiency get it done
so i think honesty is what can help you
get past
oh yeah move on to the next chapter oh
yeah
yeah owning owning and owning i'm real
big on that church i tell my friends all
the time like
just own it whatever you do just own it
you know if you're homosexual
be the
you know the gayest dude around you know
i could just own it own everything you
got it when you go you're straight i'm
straight and like a very very straight
too like i've even
i've even thought to myself you know if
i were
if i were
homosexual my life would be easier
because of it some crazy women you know
but i'm just i can't i can't i
i just dang i don't have it in me you
know
like no when you're saying prostitution
that's with guys right no no no always
women yeah oh really yeah women yeah
you'll make money that way oh it sounds
tell me tell me about that oh man so um
i went out cougaring one time that's
what we used to call it
go out um
and i thought you met with guys oh no
because that's very common down here no
oh yeah it is very common um i just um
i don't know i've you know i've never um
surprisingly you're a handsome buck so i
could i i believe that you probably i've
been i've been i've been approached uh
before but um
i've always just
i just can't i'm telling like i'm so
straight man i can't like
that's great i just don't i don't know
why i don't know why and
i know me
sexual preference
and you know color your skin or whatever
that hasn't the last thing i would ever
consider when when when you know
description can i ask you to sit up
straight again yeah sorry sorry am i
better i know it's the opiate yeah yeah
exactly um
so the last thing i consider is is what
you like to do with your dick you know
i don't care about that doesn't matter
tell me about your
trust oh so i used to go out cougaring
and uh
just you know go out
with friends and see who can get you
know
the the cougar or whatever
uh
you know it's like a like an older
undersexed married woman um so
i did that and i i you know
i was um
[Music]
i was an alcoholic at the time i think
probably you know i was doing opiates as
well but i was i drank a lot of whiskey
and so i i showed her a good time and
she i remember she woke me up and
she was like um
she's gonna go do pilates or some [ __ ]
and um
i'm like oh [ __ ] you know like
trying to wrap my head around it like i
need to get up and go and listen but
she's all no just can't hang out and you
know she's all fridge is here yadda
yadda
[Music]
she also left the keys to another car if
i needed to go and do something and a
stack of money this high on the dresser
and i was like
what the [ __ ] you know i didn't know
what was going on i was gone for like a
whole week
and uh basically long story short she
passed me around her whole little group
of uh women uh
that's how i got started and it was all
the same thing i get woken up in the
morning to them already dressed ready
going to do something and they all leave
a stack of money
sometimes in an envelope
on the on the dresser or the nightstand
or something
i don't know these are married women
single women i believe the majority of
them were married however i never saw
any husband right or children for that
matter it was always a big empty home
uh obviously you don't know the
lifestyles of that judging by the
bedroom several of them were married you
know i saw men's watches on the
on the thing well i i know of some i
know several wealthy
married men who have who share
a very nice apartment
in a nice part of town that they use for
this exact purpose but with young female
yeah of course yeah yeah yeah so this
might be
their wives
maybe their bridges
i mean if it was and they got some
really nice um
house just for
there's a lot of money in this town
yeah it's true we were going to um like
um
like houses like like in my house i grew
up in like
like a
huge like
like palacios nobody these women get
divorced or they i guess so yeah you're
right yeah it could be yeah but
yeah but of girlfriends get together and
they use you never know yeah it's
basically um janet's house for uh
exactly she i got passed around um
i i think i was at a party one day i got
a party with a bunch of other young
dudes it was like some kind of like
little
little male [ __ ] party or something
where like uh
they were like
rolling dice or or doing something as to
who which one was gonna get who and like
i feel like we had
might as well had numbers on us or
something
it was a weird night everybody's playing
around yeah i don't know it's weird but
my mom's actually the one that told me i
was frosty because i didn't even realize
that's what i was for a long time
she goes well you know you're having sex
with these women and you know they pay
you money for it and she's like you know
son that's your prostitute
i'm like oh [ __ ] i am
so did it for a while
and then debt collecting those are the
worst things and tell me about debt
collecting
oh you just go and hurt people make them
pay you are you uh
are you that kind of person um not no
not at heart
i've interviewed some people who are
those kind of people i mean i don't
think i'm like i mean i do it better you
don't seem to be i don't do i i do it
very well because any job i'm going to
do i'm going to do it i'm going to do it
the best i can
that's just me like you just turn on the
switch and you can come in first well
yeah of course it's my if that's the job
i'm if that's what i'm here to do so i'm
going to do it the best because
say is like cutting grass you know say
they say you do somebody's
lawn manicuring and when someone walks
by they're going to see it and if it's
good or it's bad they're going to say
who did that first thing they say is who
did that
right
and so if i'm the one that did it i'm
going to want it to be
the question asked
you know because it looks so badass
so i i can't have my name attached to
something that's happened it's going to
be done half-assed
so it's a great position i do i do it
very well but
it's not something i
you know i don't get my rocks off on it
you know it's just like a job
uh
which is another reason why i felt like
i should have been able to do the gay
for pay thing
because the way i am with work and stuff
like that being able to put aside my
whatever schools i may have
but i can't
i just can't do that there's other
things involved in that yeah yeah
exactly i can't i just can't um
exactly there's other things involved
that's not just doing a job right
exactly you have to you have to be
present into a certain degree you know
that i just can't
yeah but you know and after that i had
already had some things in prison that
desensitized me to
violence and
[Music]
um i i do somewhat justified in my head
you know
as to how badly i would hurt somebody i
would use base it all upon
their character
and how they were
um
because uh
i had to deal with some child molesters
in prison uh i was 20 22 20
fresh fresh freshly into prison
we got three
heinous child musters come to the yard
back to back to back and i was in mac
security because i was so young and my
charges were
kind of [ __ ] up trump trumped up and
[ __ ] up
so um
youngest youngest guy in line has to do
has to
has to [ __ ] take care of the trash
whatever
and um
i didn't know what the [ __ ] they were
talking about and they pulled me aside i
was looking around for the trash can
what trash to take out i didn't know
that meant you know
get this person out of here
and i didn't know anything about i know
anything about anything i had no idea
what the [ __ ] they were talking about
when they asked if i had a piece dug
them out on a shank or whatever i know
what they were talking about i don't
know what i'm like a piece of what i i
was clueless you know
um
i never even watched prison movies i
didn't even know anything about it
really
and uh
they gave me the most
the most like
rickety
thing
you can imagine it was like
four like mini toothbrushes
welded together
to make like a thick thing of plastic
and then a chili can
i remember from an armored chili can lid
an armored chili can
they took the lid off
it's a round disc and they folded it
over just a little bit on one side
and stuck that folded in into got it hot
somehow
stuck it into the toothbrushes
and then hammered and sharpened the rest
of it flat
and that's what they gave me the first
time
to go take out this child it's a prison
weapon yeah and i remember i'll never
forget the wall i dream about it
sometimes still
the walk there to go do it
i was sweaty i never couldn't even
barely hold on
we had these big over
heart uh
foul weather jackets because we were up
north at high desert state prison
and i remember my hand was sweating so
bad in that jacket and he was way in the
furthest part of the yard
as far as away he could be it was the
longest walk
and everybody knew it
it's amazing how well the secret
there's no secret kept on a prison yard
it's like sewing circle you know
but for some reason
that secret always gets kept that man
never knows
that he's going to get whacked
but everyone else knows everyone else
knows so everyone's looking at me on
their head i mean and i'm just trying to
keep it cool
even though i'm about to like explode
you know like uh
everything like it's beating
i i can't explain to you what it felt
like i had butterflies i felt like i
wanted to puke cry you know uh run
or lay there
i don't know so weird
it's the longest walk of my life yeah
and then um
right when i was up there about to do it
i thought of it like a
like uh you know when i get to that
point i was pulling off the band-aid
like uh
i was a wrestler so i
uh i'd get real nervous before match you
know for no reason i was one but
i would always just start pulling off
bandit you know so i did that
and uh
i cut his neck or whatever
and i almost cut his head off completely
because i was just
[Music]
you know just like
like uh
adrenaline you know
and uh
but they thought it was like that was
like a badass you know
but it wasn't
i was just like like adrenaline you had
no choice in the matter
no obviously not no
you get with the program the program
gets with you so
the guy died
huh the guy died
yeah he died
and then two more after that
really yeah
but they uh
i i've had trouble dealing with it but
today
i don't mind it
so much because what they did was i saw
their paperwork i saw there it was like
multiple aggravated
sodomy on children
sexual misconduct all these things on
children
under six years old multiple accounts um
sick people you know uh unforgivable
acts
i think what i gave them was an easy way
out
you know if if if you see an eye for an
eye you know
i feel like
they didn't get it near as bad as they
should have
i feel like they should
you know be put in a chair and get hold
holes build them out for days you know
something
like that easy way out
with me
i feel like
but at first it wasn't that easy for me
how did it affect you
how long were you in prison
um
what
about almost
like nine nine years nine and a half
years
how did those three events affect you
afterwards
oh they made my prison it made my prison
life much better
um i was instantly elevated to uh
you know not many people have that
opportunity i guess that opportunity you
know
and for considering that that life
that's that life without life is it's
the game you know
in that game
i did exceptionally well um
even the cops called me rambo um
the cops would um
jokingly they
they bring over a stack of mail that one
of them
brought over his mail and he goes he
goes yeah right right write his daughter
back you know uh so like
you know just joking around with me and
[ __ ] like that like
and i remember that kind of [ __ ] me a
little bit because i saw this juice mail
and i was like oh [ __ ] it's you know
then i got kind of soaked in like a you
know i
killed this dude you know
um so i remember that male really kind
of [ __ ] with me a little bit
uh
but they bring me over his canteens in
store like from his locker is his
his belongings like you know the food
and
everything
after each one they'd come through on an
account and they'd bring you big old
bags of their stuff and
and uh
yeah it was all new to me now now i'm
it wouldn't bother me so much but it was
just new to me
so going through their stuff you know it
was
it's really heavy for me
you know at that time sure
but you
know regrets what regrets do you have in
your life
regrets
oh very few
um regrets
[Music]
oh
i regret lying
i regret i forget some of the lies i
told
because um
yeah
so i don't do that anymore
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
treat other people how you want to be
treated
if you don't want it done to you don't
do it
to anybody else
it's the easiest way not to be a piece
of [ __ ]
i think
all right zach
thank you so much for sharing your story
yeah
thank you wish the best of luck out here
oh yeah awesome
you